how are you greetings cristian cásseres with
his brief news now in
spanish we start with doctor jesús
jara the former superintendent of sisi
sleepy of 2.6 million dollars after
being fired jara will stay
until december first in the
position he notified that  You work in a
dominant and aggressive environment and you
suffered harassment from several
members of the board of directors.
Meanwhile, now some are reconsidering
the possibility of firing you. The
president of Venda Cavazos said that they
will meet to discuss this option.
We are about to see.  an increase in
travelers at the airport they want me
after the return of
international travel we are talking about more than 30
countries one of the airlines that will
take care of this is reversión airlines
is the first flight from london will arrive in
las vegas today for example this
airline has flights from london to
las vegas' four times a week
so welcome to all since to  Something was
received by the golden knights
las vegas style as you can see
this happened on sunday at bareback
but the new player needs to
have neck surgery before he can
take the court the golden knights
gave alex storr gates and crafts and
low due to the fact that last week
tomorrow the team was preparing to
face ciaron and we started the
week with pleasant temperatures here
we present the forecast for the
week where we can see that today we will
reach almost 80 degrees the rest
of the week will be really very similar
Without traces of rain I am Cristian
Cásseres with super informative news about
Kirchner or in Spanish good day
[Music]